maybe it's lovely to see here on flicks
in the city again as always now we're
just after the premiere of your new
movie the falling in which you're the
lead actress in your first big film how
did that feel absolutely amazing very
nerve-wracking but uh yeah I'm really
really glad that the final piece was as
good as we hoped it would be and yeah
everyone's really enjoyed it so far so
yeah it's exciting and of course is a
quite a big cast in this film isn't the
mainly young actresses cuz it's set in
an all-girls boarding school in 1969
you've got a very close relationship for
close friendship with the character
Florence Pugh player Abbey your
character called Lydia now how did it
feel kind of being the more experienced
person leading that cost of newcomers
whereas when you started on Game of
Thrones many years ago you were that
newcomer weren't you yeah no I mean it
was really really exciting to have that
sort of experience behind me but
honestly on set you wouldn't have known
that the other girls were very new to
this they all behaved very
professionally they all seemed to know
exactly what they were doing even if
they didn't Florence was absolutely
amazing this was the first role that she
ever got and you know never thought
honestly about acting and never thought
that this would kind of all come from
just one audition at school and it's
done absolutely brilliantly and then
from then all the success that's Comfort
come to her from it she's just handled
it all amazingly and I'm so so proud and
she was so so nervous but um yeah she's
done really well as of all the girls
they were just really really great on
set and it didn't feel like they didn't
know what they were doing or anything
like that they would have sometimes have
questions and things which I was
completely happy to answer but apart
from that I felt like it was like a
really great kind of effort and you a
great on-screen team all of you
definitely you really work well together
and you also all live which I guess help
with that on-screen friendship bonding
in the same house together didn't you
when you feel me what was that like it
was manic but actually honestly I was
really really nervous about it at school
like I had a few like female friends but
I was kind of very intimidated by a lot
of girls and I was worried that it was
going to be the same so honest
when they first said like we'd like you
to also stay together in one big house
during the course of shooting I was
immediately quite apprehensive but when
I got there and met all the girls we had
lots of rehearsals beforehand and lots
of fainting rehearsals and things like
that when we got there it was absolutely
amazing and every evening we'd choose
them what we're gonna have for dinner
and in the morning what would do for
breakfast on the weekends who don't go
out and then we do our lines together
and we watch movies and it was just
amazing and we all did have our own
space as well few of the girls shared
rooms but that definitely helped with
like kind of the bonding process but
yeah to just be with these girls when we
did have come to say goodbye it was
really really hard yeah and then even
like we started staying in a hotel it
was the end of the shoot we were in
different locations and every night we'd
like go into the one of the girls rooms
we would just sit there and watch like
Strictly Come Dancing or something so
that was like absolutely amazing and
yeah they were like a really really
solid group of girls and we've become
really close friends
you mentioned fainting rehearsals where
no people you haven't seen the film yet
cause we decide the the premiere there's
a fainting epidemic in this school isn't
there in the movie tell me what did
those fainting rehearsals involve and
did you ever get hurt yeah I mean there
were a lot of cuts and bruises from
various like flaws that we fainted on to
you during rehearsals we basically just
learned how to not hurt ourselves but
when you put that kind of into practice
and your fainting off hitting tables or
your fainting into chairs or things like
that it was um you did get hurt every
now and then but it was quite exciting
and we all like doing our own stunts so
but yeah the fainting rehearsals was
like probably one of the weirdest
experiences ever
but so so so helpful and yeah we all
really really enjoyed it and then we'd
also sort of take that back home and
then we don't be like fainting on the
stairs or like fainting here and um yeah
one of the girls that stayed with us
called Amelia he was featured in the
film but not a named character she
stayed with us too because she was
travelling so far she didn't come to the
fainting rehearsals so I remember one
evening I saw just being on the landing
I'm teaching her how to feign I'm just
sitting there thinking this is the
weirdest thing ever this is my job but
yeah it's really really great such a
different
variants have to go on your CV won't it
with your talents alongside dancing and
swordplay painting exactly on my little
spotlight page can faint well yeah now
you also get to sing in the film don't
you a little bit you do get a little
singing there and because you have heard
you sing before the game of Thrones tune
on the one of the DVDs haven't we for
the show what was it like actually
singing with other people there watching
you um well I mean throughout the course
of the shoot Cara Molly our director she
had a playlist of songs from 69 that we
all sort of listened to you and kind of
represented different points in the
story so depending on what scene we were
shooting that day we would play a
different song and myself from
philosophy so just sing all the time
Florence we used to sing all the time on
set and like when we weren't shooting or
we're waiting for lighting we don't just
be led there chillin singing different
songs so when it actually came around to
doing it it was really quite exciting
and um yeah all the little scenes where
it's kind of just music over the top and
we're just chatting or just walking or
just messing around like it was so nice
to genuinely have that sort of chemistry
with someone and sometimes it's so
awkward when they're like okay just like
bound to with each other you're like
best friends and you said that was
someone that you don't really know and
don't really like and you've got a
tyonne pretend that you've known each
other forever and your best best friends
and that was what I was honestly really
really worried about because their
relationship it's so intense and you
know so so close the I really wanted
someone I could honestly piss around
with and I really found that with
Florence and yeah I'm just so glad that
those seniors came across the way they
did because it would have felt so so
weird to have it those scenes those
close scenes with someone that I wasn't
close with and so how is it then kind of
reuniting last night for the premiere
after a long time I guess since you
wrapped the movie mm-hmm it was
absolutely amazing and I'm just so so
proud of her and she throughout the
shoot she was very very nervous
didn't have a clue of how good a job she
was doing and I'm just so so pleased of
all the kind of great press has come to
attend when
I saw her yesterday before the premiere
and she had her lovely jumpsuit on and a
hair and makeup all done and I remember
saying like back when we were shooting
like your life is going to change and
she's got such a beautiful voice singing
she can play guitar she's such a
talented girl I said to her like your
life is going to change in we actually
earlier this year went to the x-men
premiere and that was the first carpet
that she ever done and there were lots
of my fans there screaming and I
remember saying like one day like this
is going to happen to you and I think
when we were there yesterday and loads
of people wanted her photo and wanted to
speak to her she's just slowly started
to believe that this is something that
she could do with the rest of her life
and I'm just so so happy for her I mean
you can see that you both great in the
family we work very well together I can
see that you know this could be like for
her like Game of Thrones was for you and
this is your big you know your first
leading role in a big on-screen movie as
well so it's fantastic young actress
viewing British actress is kind of
really going forward it's fantastic to
see now you've got lots more coming up
as well I haven't used one as a falling
which I think is going to come out next
year next spring gosh I think it's being
the the date yeah April in moment you
also got the devil and the deep blue sea
which is in pre-production at the moment
isn't it tell us a little bit about that
gosh more of you on the big screen
yeah no very exciting so the devil
indeed breathe deeply see they sent the
script over and he immediately intrigued
me and it is such a different character
and such a wonderful story and just it's
so lovely to be asked to do another
thing in in America at the moment out
there I'm solidly known as Arya Stark
but it would be so great to do other
things and I'm massively into indie
projects I feel like you get the best
stories and the best characters out of
indie projects like not to say that one
day I wouldn't love to do a big feature
you know a big studio film that would be
very very cool but at the moment I think
me and my mom we talked about the
transition between a child actor and an
adult actor and it's so lovely to be
approached with these roles like Lydia
and like that and Evelyn deeply see
these characters that
I basically adults written and seventeen
you know that have these complex
thoughts because honestly there is no
time when you think oh I'm a kid oh my
I'm an adult like there's a slow
transition I think that's what we're
trying to do on screen and ya know I'm
very very excited and I'm very excited
of about the look of the the film as
well my character has a very unique sort
of style and it would be nice to play a
role that has a certain look a lot of my
characters don't are very sort of plain
so it would be nice to sort of step into
a role with an accent and with you know
certain hair and makeup and become
someone else that's really exciting and
who can we look forward to you working
with Matt film Jason Sudeikis Jessica
Biel sorry and I think Justin Timberlake
will be doing the music see that's very
exciting to you and we were SDCC in San
Diego this summer as you were and Sam
Raimi was there talking about the Last
of Us and he's very keen as are a lot of
people out there to see you in the lead
female role in that film as Ellie so
what are the chances they'll happen do
you think well I have a lunch a little
while ago and we spoke about you know
the possibility of me playing Ellie and
that's really exciting and I would
absolutely love to you and it kind of
all came about on Twitter a long time
ago the power of Twitter like still
never ceases to amaze me
but yeah I went for a lunch and we spoke
a little bit about it and then they
announced at Comic Con that we'd spoken
about it and since then like in every
interview people have been asking me
about it and honestly I would love to
you and I think they would love me to
play Ellie also and that's where it is
at the moment there's no script no
director it's still very early days for
the whole project but if it all goes
ahead soon enough I think yeah I would
love to and you were gave me yourself um
well I'm more of like I play with my
brother when he's got no one else to
play with I wouldn't cool I don't know I
like watching people game but I'm not
very good at it myself but I love like
the fact that you can get so engrossed
in
story of a game and people say it's just
video games I think we see with the Last
of Us and many other amazing games that
you know you can get so engrossed in the
characters and the story and I love how
you can manipulate and change the story
to come to you know different outcomes
and things like that you mentioned kind
of big studio features before and of
course some of the biggest are the Star
Wars maybe which are coming back and you
got when Christie and also not with your
MOU Syria for the well in Game of
Thrones you were going to be in that
movie now
now if JJ Behrens put that call in to
you Maisie what would you say I would
love to be part of the stars I remember
watching the whole Star Wars when I was
younger with my brothers and sisters and
my dad being extremely confused but it
would be very very cool and I think like
something like that is so iconic that
you know it doesn't matter kind of what
the outcome of the whole thing is it's
like it's something so amazing to be a
part of but yeah I love to you and yeah
I'd loved I'd love to work with you know
that and work on that sort of set with
that sort of budget and that kind of you
know that would be very very exciting
but um yeah I don't know at the moment
I'm like indie projects - how good do
you think you'd be with a lightsaber
amazing I mean I already sold fie and a
lightsaber I think that's just like a
step up and I totally take to that like
a doctor would do and of course you
mentioned last time well one of those
times he spoke about the kind of
parallels between is dark and Clara is
character hit go in the kick-ass movie
so that made me kind of think with
people like Joss Whedon saying you know
we need more female superheroes we do
you be kind of open to that sort of
thing what kind of thing would you like
to do in the superhero world that's
really interesting that you should say
that and there's not much I can talk
about but there's actually been a very
exciting project and a very exciting
group of people who have approached me
about a new series I can't say the title
I'm not saying anything about it but
it's in that sort of superhero vein in
the same vein as kick-ass where you know
the superhero is not super
and just has great intentions and that
would not be happening yet it would be
happening in a few years but something
that we've been in talks about for a
little while and I'm really really
really excited about Oh sounds
intriguing I mean would it be mentioned
kick-ass there which were a fan of
aren't we would it be that kind of
adaptation kind of well it's a comic
book adaptation no it was originally
written as a graphic novel and then the
woman who kind of had the idea about it
one of her friends said listen we should
make this into you know either a movie
or a series or and I think if they just
kind of ran from there so it was gonna
originally be written as a graphic novel
it's not based on anything it's
completely it was kind of inspired just
from walking around comic-con and seeing
so many women dressed as these almost
sexualized female superheroes and just
thinking you know if I was a superhero I
just want to wear a hoodie and jeans and
kind of taking that and making it into a
superhero that isn't wearing spandex and
isn't a sexy Catwoman or you know that
sort of thing and yeah just something
that I really really enjoyed when she
soft spoke to me about it
lots more about I'm here taking my
fingers crossed those are cool projects
on the go and obviously I got to ask you
a little bit about Game of Thrones how
is it compared going back to shoot
season five today's previous four season
season five not just for Arya but for
the whole story is a very strong one and
there are scenes that I've gone through
in red this year for arias storyline and
four other storylines that I've just
been I'm so so excited to see and are
being part of such a massive kind of
machine I don't get to be on set for a
lot of scenes that are shot so just to
see how they're gonna do it and I Finn
speak like usually I read the scripts
and I keep it to myself and then I you
know go on and shoot my best but this
year like every director I'm like what
are you gonna do for this bit like you
know this bit that's in your episode how
are you going to shoot that what are you
going to do with this and is that we're
going to be real are you going to see
that and I've just literally anyone that
I can find I've been asking questions
all the makeup people and all the
prosthetic people like how are you gonna
do this bit and it's just so so exciting
and I've never been so engrossed into
like the scripts as I am this year and
yeah like after last year's finale I'm I
can't I can't wait for the new year and
that sounds so so weird being part of
the show that you're such a massive fan
of but as the show's picking up and
getting more intense for every storyline
honestly I'm such a massive fan you
sound like a little director in the baby
yeah I mean one day maybe I didn't think
I could ever handle something as massive
Game of Thrones but I'd love to do like
a little indie thing what can you tease
if you blow there he were kind of dying
for next year to come around by a
storyline area in the new season she
makes a big change very early on which
you know usually you're excited for sort
of like episode 9 or episode 10 for your
story and they're just really great bit
but that doesn't happen till episode 7
or this year from from episode 1
you know people for me I couldn't stop
flicking for arias scenes and that's
really really exciting when you get
people's attention from like the
beginning yeah that's what I'm looking
forward to so a big change in area from
from the star and it doesn't happen
gradually like it has over the other
years I mean if you could like react to
tell me how you reacted when you saw
some of the big scenes in season 4 like
for example Oberyn Martell vs. the
mountain that was pretty strong stuff
how'd you feel when you watched that
on-screen I was absolutely amazed and um
like every time you think Jesus I just
did a really hard stunt scene like I'm
so great a sword fighting you watch a
scene like that and you're just like oh
my god but uh it's so so brilliant and I
know that day was really really hard and
Pedro on set they were shooting that in
Croatia and I'm at the end of shooting
like he was his final bit and he like
run ran and like jumped in the ocean and
like that's really really cool but
totally like I can see why that was a
long long day for the both of them
ya know looked amazing and like
sometimes you just so I wish that you
could have been there for when they shot
it but then it's also great to have that
like you know you read it on paper and
you watch it on screen and just see how
it kind of infuses everything it's great
and furans two lines we've got a family
and he's been told that you know about
the flying you will fly I mean what do
you think that means and and do you
think walking could run in the family
yeah I mean in the books I know the
walking runs throughout the Starks so I
was like I can't wait from you know Aria
to walk into Nymeria and then I'm area
like left in episode 2 or 3 of season
one yeah and uh that's really really
exciting and I think last year brand
storyline really really picked up and
people for a long time were questioning
where it was gonna go and then after
last yeah they've realized that you know
bran can be an extremely strong
contender just because he doesn't have
his legs it doesn't mean that he can't
do other things and that's what I love
about the show is that you every time
you think how you rule that person off
he hasn't got any legs like it takes a
massive u-turn and all of a sudden ya
know I'm excited for it and um yeah I
think for a cast member as well that's
really exciting when you get a scene
like that you're not sure where they're
gonna take it but um it's gonna be
somewhere really really great well I
hope so because the Starks are really
not having much luck at the moment we
heard that Tommy Letitia he played Jack
and her car is gonna be returning you're
looking forward to working with him
again that's been rumored yes you have
to wait and see
and Gendry hopefully we're gonna see him
because we've missed him for whole
season haven't we Zaki yeah Joe wrote a
really funny stay as last year like a
tweet just saying still Rowan and I love
that so yeah again she's just still
Rowan about somewhere but I think we
will see him again we have to see him
again he's such an iconic you know after
episode 2 of season 3 I think we
realized a lot about him and that he's
very very powerful person and he doesn't
really know it yet so either he's got to
turn it around and you know use himself
or someone else is going to
maybe it's always lovely talking to you
lots of luck with all your future
projects congratulations on the
screening the premiere last night and
look forward to seeing everything else
you do thank you very much it's great to
speak to you again
you